hello we're glad you've joined us for
today's webinar model based learning in
psychiatry i am christina mahalik of
labyrinth and i'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by Lavery's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning to learn more visible at
ritsz.com
let's get started you can post questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems of seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report the problem by clicking on the
green a Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free consuming
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits it is
now my pleasure to present today's
speaker Valerie Boone MD PhD neuro
psychiatrist and principal investigator
Department of Psychiatry behavioral and
clinical neurosciences to do University
at Cambridge Valerie Boone is a
neuropsychiatrist and neuroscientist at
the University in Cambridge
she is a Medical Research Council senior
clinical fellow she completed her
psychiatry residency at the University
of Toronto a research fellowship at the
National Institute of Neurological
Disorders and Stroke in the pH
in neuroscience through the University
College London her research group uses
multimode approaches to understand
mechanisms underlying impulsivity and
compulsivity across repetitive behaviors
dr. Gunes research group focuses on
mechanisms underlying impulsivity and
compulsive and hostility and revelant
two disorders of addiction across both
drug and natural rewards she uses a
multi-modal approach including in Tomica
and functional MRI pet pharmacological
challenges computational modeling and
cognitive neurosciences she has
published extensively with over 100
peer-reviewed publications including in
hit high-impact journals such as neuron
Molecular Psychiatry Lancet neurology
annals of Neurology brain and Biological
Psychiatry she is a fellow of the
American neuropsychiatric Association
dr. moon will now begin to her
presentation the floor is all yours
many thanks Christina and thank you to
the organizers for the invitation to
speak it is very much a pleasure to be
able to do this I'm going to talk about
model based learning which is
essentially goal directed learning and
model free learning resource habitual
learning will see how it's relevant in
psychiatry I'm just going to go over a
couple components and it's a large topic
we're just going to focus in a few
aspects here so obviously because the
the nature of the topic I'm going to
spend some time defining what is
model-based goal directed learning and
what is Malfi
learning well look at its underlying
neuroanatomical correlates and its
neurochemical core that specifically in
human studies and then we'll investigate
how it might be potentially relevant to
psychiatry so when we think about the
decisions that we made it so any any
decision it's actually a competition
between strategies so it's two different
strategies either the goal-directed
sister and whether habitual sister and
they exist in parallel they're
cooperating or competing and I'm gonna
give you just a very concrete example of
this so say for instance you're driving
in your car so this image here and you
are you always when you drive home you
always turn right to go home and you've
been doing this for 20 years to drive
home and you turn right to go home and
that that becomes over learned and
habitual but if you then make a decision
to move home so that you actually have
to drive in instead of turning right you
actually have to turn left to turn you
home that is considered a new outcome
and you require more goal-directed
resources to perform this so say for
instance if you have just moved to a new
home for the first couple of weeks
you'll actually be taking to account
this final goal this outcome this new
home and you'll actually make the
turning left and this is a mapping and
you're in your mind or your brain of
what you what you predict the outcome
should be in what you what you expect
the outcome to be and the steps required
for this okay it is much more
prospective this much more demanding and
requires more intention and in contrast
if several weeks down the line you then
are very stressed out at work you
working memory as engaged and thinking
about work
perhaps stress for the issues at work or
at home all of those kinds of components
are going to shift you towards a much
more habitual strategy so away from a
goal-directed outcome-based strategy and
then you're going to be more reliant on
these over-learned stimulus-response and
things and what you what is you've
learned retrospectively in what we call
more model free and more automatic and
you'll end up turning right and go into
your old home so that's sort of the
arbitration between goal-directed and
habitual behaviors and these parallel
systems now what there's a very nice
preclinical evidence in a very
compelling theory basically in
addictions from very Everett's group and
Trevor Robins suggesting that in the
context of addictions we get a shift
from goal directed towards habitual
behaviors with extended exposure to
chronic substances and their shift also
of engaging more ventral striatum
regions to it's more dorsal serrated
regions so we're going to start looking
at a little bit of this ok so why are we
interested in in this well we're
interested in it in the context of it as
a cognitive process that might be an end
of phenotype so meaning that it might
play a role in terms of how we
understand brain based
brain base function and how it might
translate into behaviors so this
cognitive and a phenotype that
represents sort of the transition
between brain and behavior if you will
and we can think about it in terms of
brought more broadly other forms of
cognitive processes that are
characterized by behavioral and
flexibility so how able are you to to
shift between choices shift between
strategies if something in the
environment changes so depending on
changes in environment
contingencies of context or if a
negative outcome comes up how able are
you to shift between your choices and
your behaviors and this is one form that
we're looking at there's a range of
other forms of compulsive aney or
behavioral and flexibility but I won't
talk about them in the context of this
talk so we're going to focus here on
goal directed and habitual behaviors and
again what we're interested in is how it
might map trans dimensionally
or trans diagnostically across a range
of a range of different psychiatric
diagnoses so we're interested in how it
might link certain behaviors so say for
instance drug rewards this kind of
repetitive drug seeking behaviors that
persist despite these negative
consequences or it might make certain
natural rewards like binge eating
disorder for instance where you're very
rapidly taking a large amount of food
despite negative consequences and
despite feeling very full or how many
linked with something like obsessive
compulsive disorder where you have these
compulsions where you're washing your
hands repeatedly to try to avoid an
aversive outcome so meaning to try to
avoid something that's negative or that
negative feeling associated with anxiety
in the context of obsessions so what
we're looking at is how does goal
directed or habitual behaviors link
across these compulsive behaviors that
map across a range of different
psychiatric diagnoses okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to start to define
some of these goal directed and habit
tasks and you're going to focus in on
the human studies so classically when we
think about goal directed and habitual
behaviors we use these over training and
evaluation
and so let me walk you through them so
this is the idea that a rodent and an
instrumental training task learns to
associate a stimulus so the lights and
pairs that with a response of the beaver
press in order to retrieve or be able to
receive an outcome the food reward and
when the rodent just receives limited
training of these associations so it's
learning to pair the stimulus with the
outcome or the response with the outcome
if you then devalue the outcome or
devalue the reward by either feeding
them to satiety in that particular
reward or associating it with something
aversive then if you test them in
extinction meaning that you then test
them without the outcome the rodent will
continue to leave repress for the
outcome that still values the food
that's still evaluated but it will stop
leaver pressing for the outcome that's
been devalued okay the one that's been
there for long but in contrast if you
then have the rodent over train so
meaning that you persist in exposing
them to this this instrumental learning
paradigm then what happens is the
outcome and they become less sensitive
to the value of the outcome and they
become much more reliant on the
stimulus-response associations or maps
and what that means then is that when
you test them an extinction without the
outcome present they'll continue to
press the lever even for the outcome
that's been devalued because for the
outcome that's no longer valid that
continue to leave a press as they're
leavin pressing also for the value for
the outcome and that maintains its value
so that's kind of the classic definition
habet this persistent responding despite
at to a devalued outcome in the context
of extension okay and there are tasks in
humans that have actually run these
studies and so they've over trained on
two specific instrumental tasks and then
devalued one by feeding to society and
some kind of juice outcome for instance
and this particular one that I'm showing
you here is actually won by Senator
which is a very nice task looking it's a
slicks of action tasks and I'll just
explain one component of it so in this
task and there's an over training
component and you learn to associate a
stimulus or cue which is a fruit cue you
learn to associate with either the left
or right button and it then is
associated with a specific outcome which
is another freak but what another fruit
outcome there's several components to
the testing but I'm just going to walk
you through one component of it which is
the slips of action tasks and this
component here and what you see here is
a virtual devaluation of one of the
outcomes so they're told that when
outcomes no longer rewarded and then
they're showing a series of cues and
they're then tested on whether they
continue to respond even though that
outcome has been devalued no are several
other components or tests but to the
task I think that's just one component
of it is called slips of action ok so
there's these tasks that tap into the
test via over training and evaluation
they very much come from the new rodent
literature on how we conceptualize
goal-directed individual behaviors and
then there's another body of tests with
another body which looks at sequential
or multi-step tasks and it taps into
similar concepts and you'll see that
actually the neural substrates are not
dissimilar
and there is overlap between these two
forms of Tennyson's but what this one is
doing is actually looking at more of the
continual arbitration or trade-off
between goal-directed and have been
learning I'm going to walk you through
this particular task and it takes in two
it assumes that habit is based on the
selection of an action that has been
previously reinforced or previously
rewarded so it takes that kind of
concept and it puts it into this
particular cons
so here the subject chooses one of these
two stimuli at this stage and it leads
either commonly the common transition
70% of the time into a second stage or
30% of time into the other stage so this
is the common transition this is the
rare transition then the subject chooses
from one of the two stimuli at the
second stage and then this is
probabilistic chance of them receiving
the reward or not receiving the critical
component is this transition component
of whether it's a common transition 70
percent of the time or an uncommon rare
transition 30 percent of the time I'm
going to walk you through what that
means so it's two different ways that we
can approach these analyses so I'm going
to walk you through the behavioral
analysis just so you have some kind of
idea of what it means to be model based
versus model three now walk you very
briefly through the computational
analysis so in this behavioral analysis
say for instance you choose this
highlighted stimulus and there's the
common transitions of 70% of their time
they're in transitions towards the blue
states and you then choose stimulus and
you win money you can then plot out what
you are likely to do at the subsequent
subsequent trial so are you likely to
stay at this stage or you like
leadership so you're looking at the
stage
strategy in the subsequent trial in
stage one he can plot that so you look
at you plot it with state probability
now the interesting thing and the
crucial component is what happens when
there's a rare transition okay so let's
say for instance you then select this
stimulus and there's this weird
transition so you end up thirty percent
of the time to this state you then
choose a stimulus and you win okay if
you are more habitual you'll base your
action or your subsequent action would
be based on what was previously
reinforced or an action that was
previously rewarded so because the
action was previously rewarded your next
state your next choice will be touched
to stay with that same stimulus so you
can again plot that so in contrast what
happens if you more a model-based from
our goal directed you'll actually take
into account the entire model of the
structure of the task you'll take into
account specific of that transition and
recognize that shifting so switching to
the opposite stimulus of the other
stimulus may be perhaps more
advantageous or at least more likely to
result in that 70 percent transition or
the common transition okay so there if
you plot the state probability you end
up with a decrease in the state
probability here and in fact if you then
plot out the state probabilities if
you're more goal director you'll see
this interaction between reward outcome
and transition on the top here and if
you're more habitual you'll see this
main effect of reward okay so you can
actually dissociate what is goal
directed and what is habitual now what
about in terms of the computational
model so again was as predicated on the
idea that your actions are based on your
previously your actions are based on
previously reinforced
so I'm just gonna briefly walk you
through this and just in a more concrete
way so say for instance you have the
choice between two options can you know
nothing about these options so just
pretend you don't recognize any of these
and you make the decision to choose one
of the options and in fact you receive a
reward and you really actually enjoy
having burgers which I do enjoy having
burgers so what happens is that you end
up with this prediction error in that
prediction error is this phasic dopamine
signal and that acts as a teaching
signal and that prediction error is the
difference between what you actually
receive versus what you thought you are
going to get it and that then that's as
a teaching signal to update the
subsequent value so that the next time
you see either of these two stimuli
you're going to be more likely to
perhaps to select one of them because
the value has been increased the value
is updated you can actually captured
this in using a reinforcement learning
algorithm so I'm just gonna again walk
you through this so say for instance
this particular component represents the
updated value and some immune value and
all that consists of is the previous
value used to what you thought it would
represent it before what you thought the
value was updated by prediction error
and so this phasic dopamine signal and
what that prediction error is is
essentially the difference between what
you actually received versus what you
thought you were going to receive okay
so you can capture all of these elements
and this allows you then to actually
formalize this measure of habitual or
model-free learning there is also this
learning rate so the more likely you're
to use this prediction error
- then subsequently shifter behaviors
the higher your learning rate that's
individualized so in this particular
two-step task you can then use that
reinforcement learning algorithm I
Justice find and can use that to capture
the model three components and you can
separately look at a model based
component and there the model-based
component as I described previously
takes into account specifically the
probabilities of these transitions and
also the values that you have signed to
these states but what we're most
interested in is this net action value
combining the two and looking at a
hybrid model and specifically we're
interested here in W the measure of W
and that what that is is a net action so
the the net component and an arbitration
between goal-directed and habitual
behaviors so if W is higher than one
goal-directed you are the lower it is
the more habitual you are you'll see
this is like oh okay and there have have
been studies that have attempted to
compare these different tasks so the
comparison of this two-step task with
another task that involves the training
and evaluation using food rewards
evaluation which most closely
approximates rodent studies and what you
see here in this very nice study is that
the more a bit the more goal directed
you are the more likely you are to be
sensitive to the devaluation and what
this suggests is that there's a
correlation between this conventional
over between habit tasks and the
two-step times okay
so let's talk about the underlying
neural correlates of humans
so here the human studies very much
approximate what we
rodent studies so you see this
dissociation between frontal striking
circuitry for goal-directed versus
habitual behaviors so for the
goal-directed behavior assisted that
implicates activity in the ventral
medial prefrontal cortex or con and the
caudate and also connectivity between
these two regions for anatomical and
functional and these regions are
involved in tracking or representing
action outcome Association so it allows
you to then track these immediate
outcomes relevant to goal directed
behaviors so the types of human studies
that have looked at this include things
like
action test looking other goal-directed
phenomenon and in the studies that have
looked at kind of overtraining so on
these reinforcement learning tasks or
looked at the slips of action itself we
see that it's then associated the
habitual component is then associated
with either increase activating the
attainment and/or in the road and to be
the dorsal lateral striatum and also
increase both anatomical and functional
connectivity between the premotor cortex
and cutaneous
okay so we see this dissociation region
goal-directed regions in red and in
black the habitual regions and this very
much parallels what you'd expect to see
in rodents now what about in terms of
the two-step tasks it's the two-step
task if you what you also see in
addition to the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex is you also see the lateral
prefrontal lateral regions higher order
cognitive processing regions being
implicated particularly in this state
prediction error that's utilized in
model based learning so in a study in
which we looked at the and in which the
underlying neural correlates of state
prediction error or examined what they
see is
representation in the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex so a region involved
in planning of actions particularly of
sequences and also in learning
associations between between stimuli and
so what you'd expect them to be relevant
to tracking transitions between states
so an element involved in in goal
directed learning what you also see is a
model based learning also implicates a
region called the intraparietal sulcus
and that region is involved in
integrating sensory signals to control
the goal-directed actions so again a
very necessary feature related to
model-based goal directed learning now
if you take this two set tasks you
particularly emphasize the state
transition of the model-based nature of
it
what you see is increase activity
particularly in these lateral regions
but you do not see any activity in the
ventral striatum if you then over
trained them using a slightly different
modified version this three set version
and then you over trained them what you
then also see is greater engagement in
the putamen so you do see that again
these regions are very much in parallel
with what you'd expect to see in rodent
studies so the DL PFC for instance might
be more closely aligned to the pre
limbic cortex in rodents for instance
now what happens if you then take the
two-step task and the most commonly used
version that you set tasks and you
change they dynamically change the
reward learning contingencies okay so
you make the task more difficult they
need to learn the rewards in an ongoing
manner you then end up with the sponsor
trade-off between goal directed and
habitual strategies rather than shifting
more towards one or the other and with
this constant trade-off you end up with
this in green here an overlap between
regions in
in both model-based and model model free
learning so it involved in some state
prediction error and rewarded prediction
error and what this might suggest is
that if you were if in a task that
requires more of a constant trade-off
between strategies there may be more of
an integration between different forms
of prediction error or Deford between
model-based and model free learning
during the learning phase or during the
training variance so depending on how
the task is structured it will implicate
different regions and they're all very
much and there are very much in keeping
with what you'd expect in rodent studies
this overlap here emphasizes this wants
to trade off between strategies there is
one other region that has been
implicated in humans and this is work
looking at more anatomical correlations
so on the left here is voxel-based
morphometry this is resting state
functional connectivity this is a form
of diffusion a diffusion literature
called orientation dispersion index and
this is all in healthy controls and what
we see is that the more goal-directed
you are the greater the volumes in the
medial orbitofrontal cortex the greater
the client functional connectivity that
rests between the medial orbitofrontal
cortex and ventral striatum the greater
the orientation dispersion index in the
medial Louis okay so what's relevant
about that now we're just adding to this
the neural substrates that we've
identified and what's relevant about
this specific orbital frontal cortex
region is that it may overlap with
rodent studies which have been
attempting to dissociate model-based
measures in Pavlovian learning ok so
what I've been talking to you it has
been an instrumental goal directed
learning and here there's been a series
of
studies looking at Pavlovian classical
conditioning processes and attempting to
look at the model-based nature of this
I'm not gonna go into details in this
and I'd suggest you look at some of the
studies that have been previously
published by Sean bond and the idea
behind this is if you've beaten the
orbital frontal cortex you then impaired
these model base elements associated
with Pavlovian learning and here it's a
similar concept that it's an attempt to
try to mentally simulate an outcome or
to infer or an outcome based on what you
understand about the task structure but
the associative task structure so
conceptually the medial orbitofrontal
cortex may actually overlap between
model based learning and instrumental
processes goal-directed processes and
Pavlovian classical conditioning
processes but again given the
limitations of time I'm not going to go
into detail on this okay so just an
interim summary there is evidence for a
dissociation between front-row straddle
circuitry for goal-directed and habitual
learning and they overlap and they're
converging were overlapped between
animal and human studies they learn the
regions involved in goal directed
learning are involved in elements
relevant to model-based learning so
tracking and immediate outcome or
tracking the state transition or
integrating sensory signals with goal
directive actions and if you then take
the task and you emphasize this
trade-off of the arbitration between
strategies so many of the subsequent
tasks can talk about machista actually
use this particular format what you end
up doing is then you're emphasizing this
arbitration between the two strategies
and the neural regions then are more
likely to overlap and suggesting that
both forms of prediction error State for
dictionary
and word prediction there might be
utilize concurrently during the learning
process and then the orbitofrontal
cortex
again more studies need to be conducted
in these may perhaps suggest component
related to a simulation of an outcome or
inferring an outcome based on the known
previous tasks or associative structure
of the task it may represent an overlap
between model-based learning across
these goal-directed instrumental tasks
and Pablo conducts okay
so there's actually a range of neural
chemicals that have been associated with
goal-directed the habitual behaviors and
includes things I gather glutamate but
really only dopamine in certain and have
been studied in humans I'm going to
focus in on dopamine and serotonin so
here this is looking at dopamine and in
the rodent studies you're able to
conduct more anatomically specific
targeting so for instance in rodent
studies if you have a dopaminergic
deficit or lesion influencing the
substantia [ __ ] which projects to the
dorsal lateral stride or the putamen you
end up decreasing habitual behaviors you
get a slightly different picture in
humans probably because of the lack of
anatomical specificity but the picture
is actually fairly consistent in humans
so in healthy controls if you give them
each tyrosine depletion which decreases
the precursor of dopamine
but kind of general dopamine depletion
paradigm you end up at least in women
not in men but in women you end up
shifting towards habitual behaviors in
healthy controls again if you give them
be the dope which is a precursor to
dopamine you end up increasing
goal-directed learning it does seem that
across the board most of the studies
seem to influence more goal-directed
learning than habitual behaviors so in a
part in a patient with Parkinson's
disease Benson so Parkinson's is
characterized by a deficit manner jerk
neurons within the dorsal lateral
projection to the dorsal lateral
striatum or the putamen and what you see
here is that when the Parkinson's
patient is off medications so with the
dopaminergic deficit you see a decrease
or an impairment and goal-directed
learning and then once are on not on
medication CC this normalization of the
goal-directed learning we actually don't
see any impairments in habitual learning
and again there is another study also by
Senator Witt suggesting that the more
impaired you are or the greater the
severity but part of Parkinson's the
greater the impairment of the
goal-directed deficit so again very much
focusing on this model-based
goal-directed deficits and in healthy
controls if you look at the underlying
presynaptic dopamine synthesis using 18
fluorodopa what you see is the more
goal-directed you are the greater the
presynaptic dopamine synthesis and the
right ventral striatum in healthy
controls okay so what about the role of
serotonin and there is indeed some
evidence both in animals and humans for
potential role for certain and that may
be influenced by the outcome valence
okay so if you take a rodent and you
overexpress 5ht
receptors in the dorsal lateral striatum
or the human putamen you can increase
goal-directed behaviors and rodents okay
similarly if you take rodents and you
expose them to you you run a lever
pressing study in which they can lever
press for cocaine what you see is two
different types of animals two different
groups of animals emerging so those that
continue to compulsively lever press for
cocaine
despite experiencing flex aunts and
those that are able to stop lever
pressing on what when the for cocaine
when they're experienced in the foot
shops because so that group that
continues to compulsively cocaine seek
is represents about 20% of the rodent
population if you look at that 20% what
you see is it there's less serotonin
turnover so fewer certain and
metabolites in the prefrontal cortex and
what you also see is if you take that
rodent that that compulsive high
compulsive rodent population and you
expose them or give them high dose
citalopram we can then reverse these
habitual behaviors so they become less
compulsive on high doses of citalopram
if you take rodents across the borders
and you then you then do a for brain
serotonin lesion so you decrease
serotonin in the forebrain you can again
decrease this habitual behavior so
they're less likely to compulsively
cocaine seek under punishment and
similarly you can in you can influence
this using 5-htt to see receptor either
agonists or antagonists in opposing
directions so again overall suggesting
that serotonin transmission in the
forebrain may be related to
of cocaine seeking or compulsive
habitual behaviors under punishment okay
so there is fairly extensive evidence in
humans that is to link serotonin and the
representation of losses and aversive
learning but there there is also
evidence to link serotonin with reward
processing systems so here this is a
primate study looking at measuring the
dorsal raphe firing rate so the firing
rate of search logic neurons and using
the secod tasks and what you see is that
the firing rate of the search emergent
neurons increases both in the
anticipation of rewards and then
receiving rewards so suggesting a
potential war for rewards and certainly
also in human studies this is just one
example using a four on bandit task in
which the outcomes of reward and
Punishment are dissociated what you see
is normally the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex encodes the values of the
expected rewards but what you end up
seeing is in the context of tryptophan
depletion where you're centrally
depleting serotonin healthy humans have
this decrease in the end PFC activity in
terms of encoding reward values so again
this might suggest that serotonin might
play a role in terms of the
representation or encoding of reward
values and there's been an argument that
it might play a role in terms of
representation the long line outcome of
rewards and what about in terms of the
arbitration between habit and goal
directed behaviors so this is a healthy
volunteer study in which who in such in
in the subjects of undergone central
serotonin depletion using tryptophan
depletion and what you see is that
increasing serotonin levels centrally
ends up with it shift towards more
habitual behaviors on the slips of apps
and similarly we have shown also using
the two-step task that serotonin
depletion can also have an impact on
these strategies but it's dependent on
the outcome valence okay so it depends
on whether they're learning to gain
rewards or learning to avoid losses so
this is the two-step task and what we've
done is we've modified it so they tested
twice on either award version or a loss
version and what you end up seeing is
opposing effects so if in healthy
volunteers you know they're depleted of
serotonin and using tryptophan secretion
what you end up seeing is a shift
stewards habits for rewards similar to
what you saw previously you see the
opposing effect which is a shift towards
more goal directed behaviors for losses
so suggesting and an impact or an
influence related to the outcome of a
events so just as a brief summary of
this we see that dopaminergic
manipulations predominantly shift model
based learning towards rewards and we
see that certain American manipulations
can shift strategies that it seems to be
an unction of outcome valence okay so
how is this relevant to psychiatry this
is the last part of the talk and here
we've attempted to look at behaviors
that might be characterized by
compulsive Atene so this kind of
repetitive behaviors and what we've done
here is we've looked at subjects of
binge eating disorder so there are
they're obese with or without the
injecting disorder we've looked at
obsessive-compulsive disorder and we've
looked at methamphetamine depends
so we've also looked at alcohol
dependence and I'll explain that one in
a moment but what you see here is this
over all these patient populations
characterized by compulsivity you have
this decrease in W or the shift towards
habitual behaviors okay away from goal
directed behaviors so suggesting that
perhaps impairments in goal directed
behaviors might underlie this kind of
phenotype of compulsivity now what about
the story is surrounding alcohol misuse
so it's a little bit more complex and
it's very much dependent on the exposure
or the recency of the exposure to an
alcohol binge or related to abstinence
so this is in the binge drinkers and
what you see here is a decrease in binge
drink the decrease in W or a shift
towards the virtual behaviors and binge
drinkers relative to healthy controls
and binge drinkers are a greater risk
for developing these developing these
various subsequent alcohol misuse or
subsequent alcohol dependence so they're
a high-risk group but our binge drinkers
also are have ongoing binge drinking you
can actually test them and look at how
it's related to the most recent binge
drinking episode so here if you start to
deconstruct this and you look at the
number of days since the last spring
binge drinking episode if you've been
binge drinking less than four days
versus greater than four days what you
see is a difference between the two
groups so those that have recently been
exposed to high doses of alcohol up to
four days
about sensation you see that there let
they're more likely to be impaired in
goal directed behaviors and more likely
to be habitual and that normalizes or
improves for days after the last episode
so suggesting that this influence of
ongoing heavy exposure to alcohol and
shifting towards habitual away from goal
directed and it may be that this place
of role in terms of maintenance of the
addictions indeed we see in alcohol
dependence again this influence of
abstinence so that if you test subjects
between two weeks to one year abstinent
you don't see any differences as a
function of you don't see any
differences from and healthy controls
but what you actually see now is this
effective abstinence so the longer your
outing the greater the goal directed
behaviors ok so what about in terms of
sorry so what about in terms of alcohol
dependence and again as I said we lose
this effect between groups whether you
test them at two weeks or whether you
test two weeks abstinence or two weeks
to one year abstinent in fact what we're
starting now starting to see now is
actually that there may be a predictive
component related to the neural activity
okay so this subjects are scanned on
this two-step task at two weeks of
abstinence and we look specifically at
this state prediction error activity so
this error activity an assertion with
model based goal directed learning we
see that it's associated in the
ventromedial prefrontal cortex and if
you then follow these patients out of
abstinence so you and you follow whether
they're abstinent or relapsing what you
see is that those that relapse of
decrease activity compared to healthy
controls in this specific region
associated with model based state
prediction there
activities suggesting that neural
correlates of model-based learning may
actually be predictive of relapse and
alcohol dependence so very nice finding
by Miriam support
now Karen era has also run a very nice
study looking at cocaine dependence
again active cocaine users using this
using the sips of action tasks and what
she shows as an impairment and
goal-directed learning so the
instrumental phase so impairments in the
use so learning the associations between
responses and outcomes and also an
enhancement in habitual learning so the
tendency to continue to respond
despite devaluation of outcomes so both
this impairment and goal-directed
behaviors and enhancements and how that
learning and there may be a more
specific effect with regards to aversive
outcomes in obsessive-compulsive
disorder so this was not shown in
cocaine dependence but it was shown in
obsessive-compulsive disorder so here
these subjects learned to associate a
stimulus with a particular response to
now avoid something aversive and in this
case avoid and aversive shock and then
the shock once it over trained on this
the shock is subsequently devalued so
they're told that no longer its
experience of shock and the pad is
actually removed from their hand and
what you see in the obsessive compulsive
disorder patient so these are patients
who may perform compulsions to try to
avoid a negative outcomes which are
trying to avoid the anxiety or the
associated with the obsessive with the
obsessive thought what you see here is
that the OCD subjects persist in
liebherr persists in the response
despite the aversive outcome being
devalued now when he asked him about the
urge to persist and respond
you see that the urge is also increase
so suggesting that it's not just a motor
response but there may be some cognitive
processes that may also be implicated
now again Claire Gillen has done a very
nice study here published in Elife
looking at the specificity of these goal
directive impairments so is it related
to compulsive behaviors or do we see it
across a whole range of psychiatric
disorders so she did this using an
online survey an online task and she
tested a couple thousand subjects and
here you can see here the relationship
between questionnaires that are specific
to these different behaviors and model
based learning and what you see here is
an association between model based
impairments in model-based items so
they're worse at learning goal directed
learning in subjects with more eating
behaviors impulsivity
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
alcohol misuse then she asked well how
is this a specific in some way or do we
see this across a range of different
behaviors and so she done did a cluster
a factor analysis where she took these
specific symptom profiles and then
looked at how they cluster into factors
and the three factors are anxious
depression compulsive behavior and
intrusive thought and social withdrawal
the factors of alcohol misuse eating
behaviors and OCD are clustered into
compulsive behavior and intrusive
thoughts okay and importantly you then
see that impaired model based learning
is specifically associated with this
factor to this compulsive behavior and
intrusive fawned so even though there
are the studies have been published that
suggests that goal-directed behaviors
may also be impaired in safer and
substance if Renia in social in song
they don't necessarily there may be in
fact greater specificity with regards to
these goal-directed impairments and what
you see here is a specificity associated
with this factor of compulsive behaviors
intrusive thoughts so just to summarize
this section we see impairments and
goal-directed learning across behaviors
characterized by compulsive 'ti and
intrusive thoughts we see that how
resent an alcohol binge and the duration
of abstinence seems to influence is
shift between strategies and a very nice
study suggesting that neural correlates
of model based learning specifically in
the ventromedial prefrontal cortex might
predict whether someone will relapse or
remain abstinent we also see that assess
a compulsive disorder we see this
impairment in goal directed learning to
rewards but there may be in effect
specific to reverse evoke comes we see a
potential role for aversive habits so
just to summarize and these are just
brief take homes they take on points
again we see that particularly model
based behaviors and to a lesser extent
model three behaviors are associated
with this trans diagnostic Transat
gnostic factor of compulsive behaviors
and intrusive fonts we see that the
neural correlates of these tasks are
actually very similar between animals
and humans
you can dissociate them in terms of
neural affront or idle circuitry into
goal directive and habitual regions to
implicate different frontal regions if
you take a task that emphasizes this
concentrate off between strategies you
see this overlap between regions
getting the ventral stream and
ventromedial prefrontal cortex and
certainly suggesting that perhaps there
may be this learning for both forms of
prediction error during during training
and we see these possible roles for
dopamine and for serotonin but again I
would be a bit cautious particularly
about the dopaminergic findings they are
consistent in healthy controls or across
them across human studies but there are
limitations with regards to anatomical
specificity and here I'd like to thank
members of my group
they've been very instrumental in
running these studies and and and
writing up these studies to my two
mentors trevor robbins and edward bull
Moore and I didn't mention some of these
studies we have some very nice PET
imaging studies at the University of
Turku looking at these tasks and the
University of Minnesota with John grants
thank you
Thank You dr. manaan for your
informative presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window and dr. Boone will
answer as many questions as time permits
the first question we have today asks
can you shift these behaviors
between goal-directed and habitual
behaviors or vice-versa and there is
actually some very nice evidence from
different groups ross auto being one of
them we're in the context of stress you
can shift towards more habitual
behaviors maybe it's dependent on your
working memory learned we also see
things like these behaviors are also
sensitive to things like your level of
neurodevelopment your age your your
working memory and also you can also
influence this by repetitive
transcranial magnetic stimulation so
these kind of transient lesions if you
will so a transit lesion that the
lateral prefrontal cortex can also shift
these behaviors but one side of it is
dependent on working memory so there's
various different strategies of what can
use to actually shift these behaviors
thank you for your answer our second
question of the day asks why do you
think we don't see changes in habits
okay so so based on the animal litter
tree you would actually expect to see a
shift in habit formation or or habit
expression in in Parkinson's disease but
I think the difficulty that you run into
with human studies is this lack of
anatomical specificity right so if you
if you give someone levodopa or you
dopamine deplete them with tyrosine
depletion you could be affecting
multiple regions so you could be
affecting the caudate putamen value
sorry no more prefrontal regions and we
also see that there's an overlap in
regions for both habitual and
goal-directed behaviors so this kind of
lack of anatomic
specificity might be part of the reason
why we don't see this shift it may be
that if we run tasks where were strictly
over training them like significantly
over training them similar to animal
studies we might start to see this kind
of we might start to see an impairment
in their actual behaviors so it may be
also a component of the task since
Holmes
thank you for your answer it appears as
though we are running short on time so
this will be the last question of the
day the last question asks do you think
there is a role or behavioral or
training I think that's an excellent
question
but can you hear me so I think that's an
excellent question and I think it's
crucial it's so what we're seeing is
that most of the shifts that we're
seeing and seems to implicate more than
goal directed and model-based components
so I think potentially if we could shift
towards greater goal directed behavior
so greater kind of prospective
behavioral choices it may be that that
might allow us to shift some of these
behaviors and that might be important
specifically for psychiatric disorders I
think if we can start to look at what
can shift the model-free habitual
components I think that would be
incredibly useful but again we're not
seen as much in terms of the capacitors
shift at least with these particular
tasks but in the context of psychiatric
disorders especially if these behaviors
start to predict treatment outcomes or
maybe a
severity the ability to be able to shift
them I think holds significant
therapeutic potential I would like to
once again thank dr. Berger presentation
do you have any final comments you'd
like to leave us with today no I don't
think so thank you for having me
involved in this it's been our pleasure
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and thank lab routes
for today's educational webcast this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
June 2017 libraries will alert you via
email when it is available replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events I'll see you next
time here at lab routes calm goodbye